science communicator and residence Adam
Becker I'm Sandy Irani I'm the associate
director of the Simons Institute and for
those of you who are unfamiliar with us
the Simons Institute is the leading
international venue for collaborative
research and theoretical computer
science we were started in 2012 with the
generous Grant from the Science
Foundation and we bring together the
world's leading researchers in
theoretical computer science and related
fields
this program the science Communicator in
Residence was created in Fall of 2016
and the goal of the program we have
multiple goals one is just to support
science journalism
also to spread the word about
theoretical computer science to the
broader Community but part of the goal
is pedagogical and that's probably where
this talk fits in today we have with us
an expert communicator and we have to
communicate our science all the time to
a broad audience so it's always good to
sort of learn how to do that better
whether it's an article for the New York
Times an interview with a journalist or
just writing a really good intro to your
paper
writing skills are always useful so I'm
delighted today to welcome Adam Becker
item holds a PhD in cosmology from the
University of Michigan he's written for
many different venues including the New
York Times the BBC and PR quanta new
scientists and he's first critically
acclaimed book is called what is real
The Unfinished quest for the meaning of
quantum physics
and that was supported by a grant from
the Sloan Foundation Adams also appeared
in numerous radio shows and and talk
shows a little closer to what we do Adam
co-authored a script on incompleteness
and the halting problem
for veritasium a popular YouTube channel
which received over 20 million views
which is a big number
um so we're very pleased to have Adam
today you've probably met him at various
teas and and events so thanks very much
Adam
thank you
so first can everybody hear me
um so as Sandy said uh I'm Adam back
around the science Communicator in
Residence this semester at Simon's uh
and I'm here today to talk with you all
about writing about science
um so let's start with some
introductions
um Sandy already introduced me
um
uh something that some of you may not
know about me is that I am absolutely
epically terrible with names if I have
met you and had long conversations with
you there's still very good chance I
don't know your name and also there's a
lot of people in this room who I haven't
met so just you know there's going to be
a lot of back and forth I'm hoping
during this and so I'm going to be
pointing and referring to People by how
they look rather than by name just to
keep things Democratic and to hide my
inability to remember names
um I also want to get a sense of
the background of everyone in the room
so to do that uh I want everybody to
raise your hand
if you are a computer scientist of some
stripe lower your hand
okay
mathematician raise your lower your hand
um
physicist
or your hand
something else in the physical sciences
astronomy geology
uh chemistry lower your hand
Life Sciences lower your hand
okay
um social sciences lower your hand
uh
writing and journalism lower your hand
this electrical engineering ah
engineering of course
engineering okay good
um
good okay so this talk is sort of
pitched at working scientists uh of all
Stripes uh with a computer science event
and also a physics band because that's
my background so let's start with a
different kind of introduction
um I'm going to show you two different
opening paragraphs of two different
popular science books about physics
aimed at a general audience
uh neither of them are very long
I'm going to commit multiple times in
this talk the Cardinal set of PowerPoint
talks which is slides filled with text
and sorry about that but it's difficult
to
talk about writing any other way no no
no please leave the door open it's way
too warm in here I'll just talk louder
um
so remember these are aimed at a popular
audience and they are the beginnings of
these two books
um and yeah okay no maybe we do need to
close the door that's getting really
loud
thank you
okay
so
uh and I'm happy to read these aloud if
that would help anyone or I'll just put
them up on the screen
um
people want me to read this out I can
read this out loud okay I'll read it out
loud black holes are the best known and
least understood objects in the universe
the term is used colloquially to talk
about an entity that sucks in everything
around it
black holes appear on screen and in
fiction they've been co-opted by pop
culture a black hole is shorthand for
something enigmatic with a Sinister Edge
I call them Einstein's monsters as a
metaphor they are powerful and Beyond
anyone's control Einstein did not create
black holes but he developed the best
theory of gravity that we have for
understanding them
that's the first one here's the second
one
in London where Southampton row passes
Russell Square across from the British
museum in Bloomsbury Leo zillard waited
irritably one gray depression morning
for the stoplight to change
a trace of rain had fallen during the
night Tuesday September 12 1933 dawned
cool humid and dull
drizzling rain would begin again in
early afternoon
when zillard told the story later he
never mentioned his destination that
morning he may have had none he often
walked to think
in any case another destination
intervened the stoplight changed to
Green zillard stepped off the curb as he
crossed the street time cracked open
before him and he saw a way to the
Future death into the world and all our
woe the shape of things to come
so we've got a
and B
but I say better
let's be better
which one makes you want to read the
rest more
who wants to know what happens next in a
let's know what happens next to B
I want to know what happens next to the
b a lot more and B is my favorite I'm
going to try to convince all of you that
b is much better than a
but there is actually a right answer
here and the right answer is B okay
uh and I know that like the idea of a
right answer with aesthetic judgments is
maybe like not how we're used to
thinking about writing but uh I contend
that uh
there are kinds of writing that work
better than other kinds of writing for
conveying various ideas
um a has the virtue of being very clear
it is extremely clear what a is about a
is about black holes
all of the sentences are very
straightforward it's fine
it's not clear what B is about B is
about this guy Leo zillard
right
unless you know who Leo zillard is you
may not know what's going on here
but B tells a story
a does not
there's no story being told here it's
just a series of facts about black holes
giving you a sense of what I'm talking
about here
here's a different paragraph a prime
does anybody see what I did here
have a look
yeah
yeah I I reordered the sentences to make
it a little bit more story-like but more
importantly I just reordered the
sentences and still makes just as much
sense if not more sense
I can't do that with this these
sentences come in a particular order
each one leads to the next one
drop something
you could drop some of them
but then you'd lose detail and I contend
that detail is actually very important
in writing in a vivid memorable
interesting style right there's very few
details here
there are no details like there's
there's facts about black holes but
um are there any images that this puts
into your head can you picture anything
that he's talking about here other than
maybe a generic picture of what a black
hole is
monsters okay good yeah
are there images here
yeah it's bristling with them
it's bristling with images detail
vividness
and the fact that it doesn't tell you
what's about leaves you wanting to know
wait what happened
when Sylvan stepped off the curb why did
it lead a way to the Future and death
into the world and all of our woe which
by the way is not an over promise
I'm not going to tell you where these
come from but I will tell you that this
is a story about how Leo Ziller came up
with the idea of uh
an atomic bomb
so this isn't hyperbole or exaggeration
I'm sorry it has cliche time cracked
open I would never write that well
maybe that's a matter of taste
yes
but
My my what I'm going to try to convince
you of here among other things today
is that a
uh
is just a series of facts and doesn't
like
convey much beyond that
whereas B is a better way of opening a
story and getting people to pay
attention to what you have to say
uh and this is the primary task that we
have when we sit down to write
uh so Tim Radford is a very very good
science writer and he this this quote
right here I think about this multiple
times a week
when you sit down to write you have to
think about the reader you have to keep
the reader in mind and think about okay
what's going on with the reader
get a mental image of what it is that
the reader wants
and what it is that they know
and what you want them to know
so when you want to write about science
or about anything you need to think
about okay who is this for
right and that goes back to some of this
as well this
reads a little bit more like a
scientific paper
this reads more like a novel
but if you're aiming at a popular
audience
sounding more like a novel might be a
better way to go
and more importantly like the the the
big thing that I that I want to draw out
with the difference between a and b here
is the difference between a topic and a
story
a is about black holes but there's no
story there
he is telling a story telling the story
of how Leo zillard came up with the idea
of an atomic bomb
when you write about science for the
public it's not enough to know what it
is you want to write about it's not
enough to know what topic you want to
convey you need to have an idea for a
story
I don't know what button I just pressed
on this thing I don't know what happened
uh
um it looks like nothing
um
anyway yeah you need to have an idea for
a story
that means you need something with
with people in it first of all
people usually care more about people
than they do about ideas
and so if you want to get someone who is
not a specialist in your field to care
about the ideas that you were writing
about
one of the most effective ways to do
that is to wrap it up in a story about
people
how do you do that
well
it depends on what you want to write
about
um
somebody give me something that they
want to write about like these people
here some of you want to be writing
something right everyone will volunteers
some topic that they want to write about
the love back and forth videos
yeah sure I'm writing about something on
the history of AI okay the history of AI
right
so the nice thing about writing about
history is
there's already a story sort of embedded
in there right and that the history
means that you're writing about the
people right
so
if you want to find stories in that
um
it's not enough to say okay well first
this thing was developed in Ai and then
this thing was developed in AI That's a
series of topics you want to find a
story you need to ask okay who developed
this thing
who developed uh I don't know neural
networks uh who did that why
what was going on
um so this is
these are the sorts of questions that
lead to stories as opposed to subjects
like if you want to write about I don't
know
um the latest results from a particle
accelerator uh you need to figure out
okay why does anybody care why was the
particle accelerator built in the first
place
who built it
that probably cost a lot of money why
was that money spent how was that
justified
what bigger picture is this a part of
and who are the characters in the story
and what are their motivations
so I have another one yeah how about the
role of plasticity in the brain okay
so the nice thing about that is that we
all have friends
uh which makes it more relatable
um and so there I you could say
introduce
a character who
uh whose story demonstrates that kind of
plasticity as a way into the subject
right somebody who suffered a brain
injury
right kind of loses the ability to do
something like Lucy's ability to talk
but then regains the ability to talk
right
that that's the kind of thing that you
want right back right yeah so you start
with characters and their stories you
take it from there but I'm also dancing
around a particular subject here which
is what's a story
does anybody want to try
doing my job for me uh and I'm Sorry by
the way I'm getting over a cold so you
can probably hear him a little hoarse
I'm fine um but uh it is a little harder
for me to project my voice than usual um
but yeah does anybody want to take a
stab at
what makes something a story
I've already called on you yeah
like key element is that conflict and
resolution
resolution are definitely important
components of story or in some stories
not all stories have conflict and
resolutions very common component story
but you you said another actually more
important word there you said beginning
these stories I would argue are made of
structure
stories have a beginning of middle and
end the middle is often about conflict
and the end is often about resolution of
that conflict it doesn't have to be well
the story really needs is a beginning a
middle end of that it needs to carry you
through
this is part of the problem with a from
the beginning
it doesn't have a beginning in the
middle in the end that's why I was able
to rearrange the sentences
I could have taken the order of
sentences and thrown them into a random
number generator and just rearrange them
however I wanted the paragraph would
have made just about the same amount of
sets
so you need to figure out what structure
you want your story to have before you
tell it
um
and the best way to do that is to figure
out what characters you want in that
story
what their motivations are
and how they're going to change from the
beginning of the story to the end of the
story and how you're going to use that
story to talk about whatever subject it
is that you want to talk about
so one very common story structure that
is used all the time in Short news
articles
is called the inverted pyramid
now this is
almost exactly the opposite of a
scientific research paper
you start with the conclusion you start
with the most important piece of
information
the most newsworthy information is at
the very beginning so if it's an article
about
a new breakthrough in
I don't know
um
about 10 years ago there was a
breakthrough in a twin crime conjecture
right where they they started finding uh
bounds on pairs of twin crimes so that
was the beginning of the article is you
know there's this massive breakthrough
in mathematics this long unsolved
conjecture uh has not been solved but
there's been major progress made toward
it
um so that's the beginning and then the
important details who did it
why how
um and then what would normally be at
the beginning of the scientific paper
is at the end of the article the
background information what you might
think of as the introduction who came up
with the twin Pride conjecture how old
is it why is it so important
yeah so doesn't that take away a little
bit from the suspense aspect I mean uh I
I remember reading many articles about
this
Direction and so on some people start by
you know he was in a barbecue when a
stroke of Genius then you're like maybe
I'm intrigued by such presentation but
maybe somebody who doesn't know what is
coming what's wrong absolutely yeah so
this is one story structure
there are many other story structures
that work this is useful for a news
article that is say less than about a
thousand words less than a page or two
um
what you're talking about which I am
going to get to you're anticipating one
of the very next slides
um is something that's often used for a
slightly longer article that would make
sense
exactly that's right so it takes time
and space to build up to something yeah
something I meant to say at the
beginning of all of this by the way
um
is that I have never given this Workshop
before you were all guinea pigs I do not
know how long this is going to take I
think it's going to take two hours if we
run over I will cut some stuff from the
end if we run under
you're on under uh we'll see how it goes
um but um but this is good you've
anticipated one of the next slides
um
so with the inverted pyramid especially
one of the most important things is the
lead uh now there's a lot of made up
words in journalism and a lot of made up
terms that we use uh like pieces of
jargon lead
pronounced like
you know lead but spelled like this is
one of the most important things that we
use
um it's basically the beginning of the
article the thing that draws in the
reader and often conveys the most
important information so it's sort of
doing double duty and the inverted
pyramid it's usually both It's usually
the most important fact in the article
the reason the article is being written
um
and it's also what draws in the reader
but even in longer articles like you
were just talking about
um
there will be a lead and it will be the
thing that draws in the reader like you
were saying like you tanzang uh have a
stroke of insight standing at a barbecue
oh what's that stroke of insight or Leo
zillar had a major you know breakthrough
idea that has changed the entire world
around us while he was crossing the
street in London oh what is that
successfully
um and one of the cardinal sins that is
very very easy to commit
uh
is called burying the lead
uh do not bury the lead the idea here is
if you were writing especially something
in the inverted pyramid format
um
something where you were starting with
the single most important piece of
information you want that up front
you want that to be the first thing you
want the reader to know what you are
writing about first thing straight off
the bat if you're writing a short
article
you do not want that
you know buried a couple of sentences or
worse a couple of paragraphs in
that will make the reader wonder why am
I reading this
you don't want the reader's attention to
wander because then the reader might
stop reading
and if they stop reading then
you don't ever read her anymore
uh
keeping the reader's attention
and
keeping them engaged in what you're
writing
is the most important job in
writing something for a wide audience
you do that by making it clear what
you're writing about
from the start
you do that by never overestimating your
background knowledge about what you're
writing about
you do that by never underestimating
their intelligence you don't want to
patronize the reader
you want to assume that the reader is a
very intelligent person who knows
nothing about the subject you're writing
about
is that many people read the paper by
just reading the first paragraph
absolutely if you want to get an idea of
the news so part of it is for the reader
intends to stop reading that's true that
is true but also it it can drive the
reader through to the later part of what
you're writing if they read the
beginning you know if you see oh your
Tang Zang has come up with this new
breakthrough on the twin Prime
conjecture it's like oh okay that's
amazing why why is there a good Prime
conjecture I think we'll keep reading to
find that out
um but this is also sort of the double
duty that the lead can serve right in
the inverted pyramid the lead is the big
headline right but in every article the
lead is what draws you in so keep
reading
um
and there are a lot of different ways of
doing that
so here are some good examples of leads
this first one is one of my favorite
leads of all time
drug lord Pablo Escobar's hippo diet the
same way
hunted down and shot by authorities
proposing a danger to the public now
this lead serves two very important
purposes it tells you exactly what the
article is about
and it makes you want to read more
why does Pablo Escobar have a hippo why
did he have a hippo why is that hippo
posing a danger to the public
it's also when I read that it's also
wonderful that there's a pun oh yeah
sure I mean that's that's just you know
yeah no it's it's a nice it's a nice
play on the idea being a danger to the
public right because the hippo is not in
danger of the public in the same other
Pablo Escobar was
um until both of them were hunted down
and shot by the authorities
um
but this is this is a wonderful
this is sort of to me the idea of what a
lead should be introduces the main
characters it introduces the subject of
the article it makes you want to read
more
it's dramatic
similarly some of these other leads
um
uh when they heard the screams no one
suspected the rooster is also one of my
favorite leads of all time although it
doesn't serve the other purpose of the
lead you have no idea what that article
is about you know that there's a rooster
involved and something went wrong
uh but it's not clear what the subject
of the article is
um
these are some leads that don't work
quite as well
don't do this
in particular the house on 53rd Street
and Huntington Avenue stood Motionless
as opposed to what
most housing is usually are emotionless
this is not a remarkable feature of that
particular house
so it doesn't really tell you anything
about what's going on it doesn't make
you want to keep reading and then
perhaps the worst lead I've ever seen
the meeting began when a quorum was
reached
that sounds both boring and
it sounds like the article is about
something extremely boring it sounds
like
like there's no reason to keep reading
that you have no idea what the article
is about
um
the first one you at least have some
idea what the article is about but it's
this weird contrast that doesn't seem to
serve any purpose why are we talking
about Lake coho in a you know in
contrast to the turbulence of the global
apparel industry
um and then since the donut time that's
just a format that is often used for
first sentences that I cannot stand uh
unless you were writing about early
Universe cosmology you should not be
using since the dawn of time and even
then I would not recommend it it's a
cliche
um
now another very important component of
writing about science is explaining
Concepts
um arguably the heart of the job of
science writing uh you know the reason
we craft a story The reason we pick out
characters and have a compelling lead
and all of that is to try to get people
to keep reading to read through the
explanation of the relevant Concepts so
they can learn something about what it
is that's going on a particular field
um
the best way to do this
is to use analogy and metaphor in
general
um and explain things in relation to
stuff that the reader probably already
knows about
um
I don't have simple examples of how it's
done because generally it's something
that's not done in one or two sentences
the way that a lead is it's something
that's crafted
you know according to whatever it is
that the article is about over the
course of several paragraphs
uh or more so for example if you want to
write about Turing machines
that's a kind of abstract concept
so first you need to motivate it you say
well what's the simplest thing that can
do everything a computer can do
so that's that's
a reasonably good motivation in part
because it's pretty similar to the
motivation that Turing himself had when
he was coming up with the idea uh and it
also is a comprehensible question to any
intelligent reader because they know
that computers can do a lot of things
um
and then you say okay well
you'd need some sort of memory right
because computers have memory what's the
simplest memory well probably a strip of
paper split into parts
like a roll of toilet paper
or maybe like a set of train tracks
with railroad ties
you know delineating each space on the
memory along the track
and then each spot either has a rock on
it or doesn't
and then you have something gliding
along that track moving back and forth
from spot to spot with a set of simple
instructions to pick up or put down a
rock or move left or right
and there's your turing machine
and so
developing that kind of analogy for an
abstract scientific Concept in terms of
something easily visualized Vivid
and simple to understand
this is why Details Matter this is why I
like B better than a there's a picture
you can see Leo Zealand stepping off of
the sidewalk you can see the little car
of some kind moving along the railroad
track picking up and putting down rocks
but analogy and metaphor can also
uh guide you with stride uh don't do
this this first one in particular which
appeared in a major publication
about 10 years ago it's pretty bad like
Omar Sharif materializing out of the
shimmering desert as a man on a camel in
Lawrence of Arabia The elusive Higgs
boson has been coming slowly into view
since last winter as the first signals
of its existence grew until they
practically jumped off the chart
the analogy serves no purpose why do we
need Omar Sharif in there at all
it doesn't do anything for us doesn't
help us understand
um now the second one I will admit is
made up that is a that is not a it is a
real sentence that someone else wrote
It's not a sentence that appeared in
print but I like it a lot because it is
a good example of
how analogies should not be used
uh wind was blowing from east to west as
if it were the sun blowing instead of
shining
foreign
to try to explain any concept especially
abstract Concepts can make you want to
do it's like oh well it's um it's like a
chicken but imagine if the chicken were
60 story stalls like then why are we
imagining a chicken
like unless unless it's well we imagine
we expected to find a chicken and
instead we found something 60 stories
tall
that makes more sense
but you know trying to save an imperfect
metaphor by making the sun Blow instead
of a shine uh
is exactly what you should not do
um
the first thing is also bad there's a
very long sentence yes
that's right yes
the shortest sentence which gets your
big message you know uh certainly
shorter sentences when explaining
difficult concepts are often better and
you're going to use a longer sentence
break it up in a more straightforward
way so that the reader can parse it more
easily you want your sentences to be
easy to parse making them short is one
way to make them easy first there are
other ways of making them easy to parse
this one's not
um now
I have an experiment I want to try uh I
want to
do an exercise with all of you
um based on everything that just talked
about
uh so I want you all to split into pairs
for groups of three if someone's left
out and then I'm gonna have to read
these two very short articles
about that
later
the best way
to get hands-on experience in a workshop
setting is to write but we don't have
time to write something so it's never
going to read
sound good
okay
um so here's what we're gonna do these
piles roughly in half
so split into Pairs and then each pair
should get one of each of these so this
is the first one
um
[Music]
one of each of these so every pair
should end up with one an A and one
for instance A and B article a and
article B at the top
IC
just split prepares each pair should
have one a and one B yeah
what I would say is everyone read read a
or b it doesn't matter which one you
read first and then yeah exactly so get
in your pairs
there's nothing on the backside of me
there is stuff on the back side
okay does everyone have
um
yeah this is a good question read them
keep an eye out for some of the stuff
that we've talked about that you should
and should not do when you're writing a
short news article
um and think about which one you think
works better and why
all right oh this is these are okay
sorry yes these are I've stripped these
of where they were published and who
wrote them they were both published for
a general audience in reasonably
well-known mid-sized news Publications
on the same day about the same subject
very comparable in that sense
foreign
speaking
French
massage
[Music]
foreign
experience
[Music]
is
this
um
I did it by myself
okay one more minute
thank you
similarities
not really the wrong way yeah
yeah so yes both of those were published
online
[Music]
thank you
so
um
who likes article anymore
thank you
yeah
article a yeah who likes article a more
B
itch
um
you're supposed to like but
yeah I don't know I'm not gonna say that
there's one that you're supposed to like
but
um
seven
what are some of the problems with
well no
um
yeah why exactly yeah why do people like
article a better
to the point I understood it okay okay
Oh I thought it was much clearer what
the point was
and like uh some of the context was also
clear
there was there was a structure in a
that wasn't there in B this surprising
thing happened
it's important it was surprising because
of this maybe there's two things that
could explain it I don't know we have to
like collect more data from the
telescope right like it it was a
narrative it was easy to follow article
edit
um
to me like the two things
sorry are what if they found galaxies
but here are too big to exist and two
like the sort of like
evolving scientific discussion about
whether it's the galaxies or the black
holes and I just feel like an article a
you get both of those much sooner in the
article and it's more exciting
like that main point was said in this
very first sentence yep
how long would it take me to say that
yeah
yeah yeah he didn't say it until like
most of the way through the third
paragraph
days out of the first sentence
B also has some problems with its state
right
uh on July 12 2022 the universe changed
forever
did it
or did it change 13.5 billion years ago
that's supposed to be a joke
yeah no I think I think it
yeah yeah okay if we want to be generous
yeah we could say that it's a joke but I
don't I don't think
I don't think that it was meant as a
joke
actually most people would probably say
I didn't even notice that day well yeah
um the other thing is that uh article B
says that the cause of the change was
that jwsd's ability to see back 13.5
billion years near the beginning of the
universe it makes it sound like
um
it makes it sound like somehow that
ability changed the entire universe on
July 12 2022.
um which is not what happened
um
so there's any briefs will want to talk
about the good things indeed
yeah
um I guess I felt like as someone who
doesn't do apology from a it was like
okay there's something surprising but it
wasn't clear how big of a deal it is
that something is bigger than it should
have been versus I feel like in B they
were kind of like I guess this is kind
of like signposting away but they were
kind of quoting experts and it seemed
like they were obviously very verified
so it felt like the magnitude of what
happens here
and I also felt like in a there was more
information so maybe it was more like
scientifically honest but I felt like it
kind of went back and forth between like
here's what we found here's the like
methods for how you would measure this
and that again I guess someone who's not
an expert in this field it's kind of
hard to go back and forth versus for B I
felt like it was kind of light on
message and it was kind of like here's
what happened and it's like super
surprising and maybe you don't do the
methods but like here's why you compare
yeah I I agree that in B the surprise of
the scientists probably comes through my
career
yeah I mean there's there's not
I do think that one of these is better
than the other but it's not like these
were both published and you know neither
one is all good or bad yeah so it goes
back I think a little for me to what you
said at this point in the story so it's
a news story I think there's no question
is
I think B may have the potential to be a
better longer story about surprise about
how the scientific process was
oh that it doesn't get there because it
tries to be something else but if your
interest if your interest is less than
the Sciences the science and more in the
process of scientific discovery maybe be
invites the reader to to understand or
Explore More of the process of discovery
and I understand yeah maybe
um I think Aid has a better job of
describing the actual process yeah
I mean we talks about telescope yeah
that's true
about the telescope and when the
telescope was put in place and that's
interesting yeah
no I do I do think that a probably
assumes a little bit more knowledge on
the part of the leader than me
um
but it's also just not clear what B is
talking about because
for a I think it's just it just feels
that he starts
um
it's too big considering it's stage and
that gives you that exercise so
okay
Hunter
discovery
I personally like to be better because I
thought it talks to read or more looking
at it or closely you see that
to make it a missed the point a little
bit but uh
during the leads going back to your
discussion of leads if the lead in a I
find rather deadly
you just don't throw that many numbers
in the opening sentence
number two so so yeah no I think that is
a fair point the lead in B is more
exciting yeah
foreign
I think his point actually uh about the
July 12th actually made me more
interested because it made me feel like
uh I was missing out what happened on
July 12th why is astronomy in a frenzy
yeah
he was fun I mean it said it's bananas I
feel like they put that in a it would
have been fantastic
no I definitely think B got better
quotes than that
yeah
okay also I don't know if they're
implements for a different audience it
feels like
a is written like more importantly
like when I saw when I read that it's
bananas at B I felt like I would have
never expected that in as like
how those differences yeah I will say a
appeared in
they both appeared on websites of print
magazines
that is mostly dedicated to science B
appeared in a magazine that regularly
covers science as a significant
photograph it's covered is not something
devoted to science
but the inaccuracy of teachers yes I
agree I feel like there's a
responsibility to be accurate yeah no I
I would be unhappy about having my name
on me
my name is
um but yeah uh no it is true accuracy is
important and B is it's a little shaky
your own facts
Okay so
now that we've sort of covered the
inverted pyramid let's talk about some
other narrative structures right story
is structure
um
the word pyramids are great for short
pieces like this but you want to write
anything much longer than
the bird pyramid is not really going to
work
you're gonna have to find some other way
um
and you will need a very clear structure
for that to happen otherwise you're
going to fall into this trap
sentences that can be in any order the
idea of sentences in any order or more
generally a list of things that can be
in any order
um
enemy of good storytelling if you are
telling a story
where the connecting beats of the story
is and then this happened and then this
happened and then this happened
you're in deep trouble
because those things could be in any
word
instead you want your connections to be
things like but
and therefore
this happened but then this other thing
happened and so therefore this other
thing had to happen you need causality
and then if you're telling a long enough
story
you'll need to have a b plot you'll need
to have a second thing going on so then
when the first thing reaches its point
of maximum
tension you say meanwhile back of the
ranch
there's nothing that's going on
the best widely known
piece of narrative that I know of that
demonstrates this as clearly as possible
uh is the Umpire Strikes Back
The Empire Strikes Back handles this
extremely well
right raise your hand if you've seen The
Empire Strikes Back
most people in the room and if you have
it you'll get the gist of it right uh
Leia and Han and Chewie and 3PO
they're running from the empire
but
their hyperdrive is broken
therefore they need to hide on the side
of this Star Destroyer or whatever the
name of the big ship is
um
until the Star Destroyer goes to
hyperdrive and they get sort of floating
away with the trash but
the uh Bounty Hunter Boba Fett follows
them
oh no what's going to happen next will
they survive
meanwhile
back on Dagobah
Luke is learning to be a space wizard
with a muppet that sounds like Rover so
it's very useful for science right
because in science writing we always
have a default the B plot is the
explanation of scientific facts a plot
that can be what's going on with your
characters what were they doing that day
what's motivating them why do they care
about these ideas and then they
encounter some adversity and then they
figure out something important and
they're about to release it to the world
and you stop
and say meanwhile wait why do we care
about this what's going on
what is this concept why is it important
at this point the reader has all this
momentum
from all of this but and therefore that
you've sent them through this uh this
sort of
uh causal accelerator of narrative that
you've shunted them through
um that they go barreling into your
explanation
and you can say okay well why does this
person care about this and now they're
identifying with the character they want
to care about it too
and so you can explain these Concepts
and take a moment and say Hey you know
this is what a turing machine is this is
what twin primes are this is what a
Higgs boson is
and then you tie it back in to your a
plot
it's one way of doing things there's
lots and lots of different possible
narrative structures once you get
outside of something short and sweet
like the inverted pyramid and the
questions that you need to be asking
yourself about how you want your story
to be structured are questions like how
would you tell the story to know is this
someone who doesn't know anything about
it
or generally why you care about it what
do your characters care about them
why do you think it's interesting why
are you writing about this in the first
place if you don't have an answer to
that question why are you writing about
it in the first place
if you don't find it that interesting
your reader is not going to find it
interesting
so maybe you shouldn't be writing about
it
your interest your lack of interest will
come through on the page if you want
your interests to come through on the
page you need to figure out why you're
interested
and then write about it from that
perspective
and keep in mind what the reader knows
and doesn't know try to remember what it
was like to not know it
and then how you learned it and what
made it make sense
what was it like not to know what a
turing machine is what was it like not
to know
what
P or NPR
would you like not to know what
you know uh genetic drift is
how did it make sense to you
yeah
so so this is one of the hardest parts
I'm maybe a theoretical computer
scientist and the reasons that I find
what I do interesting are definitely not
the reasons that anyone else wants to
hear about it
but I don't I think that may not be true
and no no let me elaborate slightly okay
okay the P versus empty question and the
questions about complexity learning
theory that I studied yeah the reason
that I love them is that I I came to
these things by struggling with Brute
Force search and with applied machine
learning problems
kind of structure stuff and some some
other things in mathematics when I found
those questions and those definitions
they changed my perspective and allowed
many patterns that I'd seen before to
sort of snap into place
without the period of struggling I have
no motivation to look at these objects
they don't change my perspective why do
I care and attempting to communicate to
people why these objects are interested
without them going through the same
experience that I did like a sensible
experience it seems impossible
they just told me a pretty good story
yeah
science is a massacre yeah I mean
yeah but but no seriously you just told
me a pretty good story and and
more importantly
um saying I was writing about you and
what you're doing right okay well you
know let's just say it was okay
um
I would need to hear that story and I
would need to find a way to convey it to
the reader because otherwise I wouldn't
be accurately conveying your motivations
and then your actions would not make any
sense and then I would not be telling an
intelligible story
so if you are a practitioner in the
field you have a leg up and that you
know what the motivations of at least
one practitioner in your field is
yourself
you you can get into the head of someone
who is like some of the characters that
you're writing about
so yeah no you can't have the reader go
through years of frustration in one area
only to find
you know
um Enlightenment and enjoyment working
in a different related field
that's not something that you can have
the reader do themselves but a lot of
the point of good writing is to take one
person's experience and convey it to
another person such that they understand
it and have sympathy and empathy for it
right
and so I don't know what it's like to go
through what you went through but I have
some sense of what you just went through
because you just told me I mean you just
gave me a story that had uh you know but
and therefore right in there right you
said I was working in this area but it
was really hard therefore I went looking
somewhere else and oh my God it was so
much better
right well I think it's it's not better
in complexity Theory you just try and
prove things that should
be true but then they're very hard to
prove oh okay but it's more satisfying
to you that's true yeah okay so it's
better
so yeah no I mean
but this is this is some of the hard
stuff right explaining
[Music]
explaining the things that you know best
um that's all been the hardest task
right yeah latest question
what level of detail
you know a lot about it but sometimes
knowing a lot about something can
actually be a problem it's still kind of
so excited about something yeah I really
like your code I can't even noted it
down we should only have the reader in
mind yes
and it really depends on who you're
writing for right I mean when you're
writing a scientific paper uh well you
know then you've got a reasonably well
defined audience right people in your
field but
um if you're writing for the General
Public
um well one answer to that question
is try writing it at one level of detail
and then talk with a friend of yours
who's not in your field and say hey does
this make sense to you or you can ask
the more pointed questions right you
know you're writing about
um
I don't know you're writing about uh P
versus NP
um and you want to know whether
um
not okay I don't think anyone in this
room
would be this silly but you want to know
whether like Big O notation is something
that most people know about it's not
um uh so you ask you know you know your
this friend of yours who is a very smart
person but is not a computer scientist
hey do you know what big on notation is
in computer science and they'll say no I
have no idea what that is what are you
talking about and then you know okay I
need to explain that or if I don't
explain that concept I need to find some
way of writing about this without using
that concept
substituting in something else right
because one of one of the things that
comes along with all this is okay what
concepts do I really need to explain
versus what things can I get away
without right which is really what
you're asking
make uh I mean another another thing
that I use when I'm running into this
problem is we'll make a list I'll say
okay the reader needs to know this
because this is the thing I'm trying to
explain
okay
if I were teaching this in a classroom
what subjects would lead up to that will
be this this this this and this okay
what can I get away without like what
can I do without
it's like uh attacking for a backpacking
trip yeah it'd be nice to have a really
big blanket but that's going to be
really heavy
I don't want to throw that in my pack is
there something I can use to substitute
for that
right
um
is there some way of talking about this
that is not the usual way
that doesn't use half of these Concepts
sometimes the answer is no there really
isn't some other way of talking about it
but sometimes you can realize wait you
know I can talk about this without using
these other Concepts right
you know you can talk about
um
I don't know
hey you're talking about the halting
problem without ever introducing the
character of David Hilbert just don't
need him it's not essential to the story
he's usually part of how we talk about
you know how Turing ended up working on
what he did
um but you don't even
he's fun
um but yeah uh
the other thing is it's like everything
else you get better at it with practice
you you know you
you construct a mental model of a reader
someone who is smart and engaged and
doesn't know what you know
and you start interrogating that reader
hey you know this you know this do you
find this sentence interesting do you
understand why this sentence follows
from the previous sentence
great what about this one and what about
this one
am I losing your interest yet
oh look the reader's gone I'm three
paragraphs in and the reader doesn't
care anymore I lost them somewhere I
need to go back and figure out where I'm
lost
so the the answer to your question is
there is no simple answer
um there's a lot of different ways of
doing it
um but it's hard and there's no simple
enough
I think that it is a good time to take a
five minute break
all right
what 250. let's get this book
I do too
um
material interesting material thank you
I think it's filled with story
and that's why that's why
absolutely
Dynamite I'm not talking about this
before
foreign
okay
[Music]
thank you yes
yes
all right
questions
foreign
there's a lot of science
yeah
I just like to find memories
but just knows nothing about
thank you
um
I really appreciate it
most people don't know
our story yeah
presenters
Especially You could argue with their
experiences
foreign
as well
everybody yeah
situation doctors that are interested
let's go ahead and get started
um
oh yeah there is a bell here I'll ring
the bell
thank you
so far
okay okay
so
so let's talk a little bit more about
how the actual writing process works
um
I only have one like good up close
example of that which is my sound
I'll talk a little bit about how I work
how I write
um
I'm going to talk about that for a
little bit
um I'm going to talk about dealing with
interviews
uh with science journalists
from the journalist perspective
um
because all of you could be interviewed
by a journalist
um and I thought that might be helpful
and then I'm just going to open up the
questions for the rest of the time and
we'll see how it goes sound good okay
so
um I tend to write long things
uh
written a book I'm writing a second book
I tend to write features I haven't
written like short news stories in a
long time
um it's rare for me these days to write
something shorter than a thousand words
um usually quite a bit longer than that
like a book
science writer well writers tend to
think in terms of number of words I
think that that's not something that
people who aren't writers tend to think
in terms of I think as a reader people
tend to think in terms of pages so a
thousand words is maybe like
three or four pages three pages of a
written book Maybe
uh something like both sides of a piece
of eight and a half by eleven paper
um
by comparison like a full published book
is usually somewhere in the range of
like 80 to 120 000 words
um
so that's the range in which I usually
write and so to write things of that
length uh there's a lot of breaking
things down to pieces and outlining
um because otherwise the work's just
never gonna happen if you sit down at a
desk and say okay I need to write a
hundred thousand words because I signed
a contract
to write a hundred thousand word book
you're not gonna write any words you'll
be lucky if you write five words over
the course of the month if that's what
you tell yourself every day when you sit
down at your desk
um instead you have to say something
like well
they have 18 months to deliver this and
so if I write 600 words a day five days
a week three weeks a month for a few
months I'll be halfway there or
something like that
um and so uh I tend to sit down and
figure out the story structure first
before I write anything because
otherwise I don't have a map for where
I'm going
uh and then I say I'm going to write
this many words a day
to
execute that outline
and then it's kind of like having
the online is a map but it's like a map
that was made a really long time ago
for you know for a trail that's probably
changed a lot in the intervening you
know
decades and so when you get to the trail
you're like oh
map says I need to go that way I can't
go that way there's a cliff over there
I need to go this way I need to go
around that the outline's wrong the
outline is is more like a gas of what I
think the story structure is going to be
there's no way to be completely sure
until you actually get in there and
write
um
I also tend to break my working day into
pieces right if I say I'm going to write
600 words today that's not that many
words but
sometimes I don't want to write and I
have to anyway
um and so then I say okay well I'm going
to sit and read for 10 minutes
something completely unrelated
just to get words into my brain because
what you read turns into what you write
and
then I'm going to write for 50 minutes
and then I'm going to do that again
until I've written the number of words I
need to write today
um
and there are other tricks too
the best and most powerful trick I think
in almost every writer's toolkit is uh
the shitty first draft
um
first draft is I I don't know if you
remember only one thing from this talk
remember that you can and probably
should write bad first drafts
if you try to write
perfect piece of writing first time you
sit down and write
you will not write anything
and what you do right will be
overwrought and over thought and
probably just bad
um
instead think about what you want to
write and just get a version of it on
the page because it is much much easier
to rewrite and edit than it is to write
so just write a draft
write a bad draft
tell yourself that you will fix it later
if you write a sentence and you don't
like it
something I'll do sometimes is I'll
write a sentence I don't like it and so
after I write the sentence I will write
in Brackets God that's awful
and then keep writing
so that way I remember to come back and
fix it because the other dirty secret of
writing is it's never as bad as you
think it is
I mean usually if I if it's so bad that
I've written that's awful next to it it
is pretty bad but I'll write a bad draft
and think this is terrible I I need to
not look at this when I walk away for a
couple of days and I come back I'm like
oh this is actually not that bad
there's some nice sorts of phrase in
here the overall structure is fine you
just need to fix it
you know it's it's a house the house is
sound
it's the right shape
it holds up you can go inside it and it
won't fall down on you it just needs a
patch some holes in the roof and maybe
reinforce the foundations it'll be fine
the other thing that I do which I also
think is extremely common
um is I keep with what I call a spare
parts bin
um people call it lots of different
things but
this is very very famous piece of
writing advice uh Kill Your Darlings the
idea is you write a sentence you really
really like it
but it doesn't matter how much you like
that sentence
um if it doesn't serve the overall
purposes of the larger piece you need to
be willing to kill it
um
but sometimes you can save those things
and also sometimes you don't want to
kill it and maybe you can lie to
yourself and tell yourself that you're
going to save it and bring it back later
so what you do is you take the thing
that isn't working you shove it into the
spare parts in a second document
that you keep with all the bits and
pieces that you thought would work but
didn't but that you might need later
and you usually don't end up rating it
for anything but sometimes you do
and it makes it easier to get rid of
those things you don't need
the other thing that will happen
especially in editing
is you'll have
two sections or something you'll end up
with a spot where you have a sentence
that's missing or you just have a bad
placeholder you know that something's
supposed to be there it's supposed to
serve as a transition from one section
to another or it's supposed to you know
explain an idea but it's a terrible
explanation it's overly the sentence is
overly long and complex you don't know
what's you know the reader is not going
to be able to understand it it uses five
different pieces of jargon
there's something wrong with it
so you just play with it you just write
different versions of it until you get
one that looks right
and if you need to break it up then you
iterate
those individual pieces of the sentence
over and over again or if you're trying
to come up with a lead this is
especially good you think okay how do I
get the reader interested in this how do
I get them interested in this early on
why am I interested in this and so you
write a sentence that tries to describe
some interesting feature of what you're
writing and that doesn't work so you
just keep going and going and going
writing a sentence after sentence that
doesn't work and eventually you get
something that has one Clause that's
right
I said you keep that clause and keep
trying again
and eventually you get a sentence that
looks good
and by you of course I mean me this is
what I do this is not necessarily what
anyone else does okay so we know that
almost everyone writes bad first drafts
the essay that is linked to in the
description for this talk on the Simon's
website shitty fur straps by Anne Lamont
she says that
um she knows of one writer that doesn't
use shitty first drafts but she
um
she thinks that uh God doesn't like that
person and that they don't have a rich
in her life
and this is roughly how I feel about
people who claim that they can write
without doing a bad first draft
um
speaking of
the writers Annie Dillard is one of my
favorite writers and this is one of my
favorite pieces of writing advice that
she had
um
Robin writer got colored by a university
student who asked do you think I could
be a writer well all the writers said I
don't know
do you like sentences
writing is native sentences uh
you have to learn what makes a good
sentence and what doesn't and I am only
aware of one way to do that
um
which is to read
as much as you can
read
adventurously uh read
things that you don't think that you
might like things that uh
are on subjects that you never knew
could be interesting but have
good writing in them
uh ask people
for recommendations about what to read
ask people who their favorite writers
are
read people who you don't normally read
you know people who aren't like you in
some way people who aren't from the
places that you're from who don't speak
the languages that you speak
many things as you can get your hands on
because what you read does turn into
what you write you will be judging what
you read while you read it whether you
know you're doing it or not
you will be deciding what you like and
what you don't like and you will develop
a voice as a writer by doing that
um
when I'm writing and I take those 10
minute breaks I'm always reading
something that is completely unrelated
to what I'm writing because the point of
those 10 minute breaks is to get my head
out of the work but the other point of
those 10 minute breaks is to get words
into my brain and so it's not enough to
just read something unrelated to what
I'm writing it needs to be
good writing or at least what I think is
good writing
um
that needs to be fuel for the fire it
needs to actually burn
so
yeah I don't have a good way of making
this transition so I'm just going to
make it that's about all I've got on my
practice of writing
I also wanted to make sure to talk about
interviews with journalists uh because
this seems like a subject that is
relevant to or could be relevant to many
or most or all of you
um there were a few facts about the
journalistic
article writing process that are
important here if you get an interview
request from a journalist
and you want to talk to that journalist
if you want to to be you know in the
article of journalist's writing respond
that day respond as quickly as you
possibly can the characteristic time
scale
of an academic article is like what
six months a year
well sure yeah uh no absolutely yes no
no I know
um
for a news article
6 to 18 hours
maybe a week if it's something that's
really on like long assignment
but yeah if you don't if you get a
request for an interview and you do not
respond that day they are probably
already working on something else and
have already found someone else to talk
with unless it's a long thing
but those are the exception of the rule
for every feature article that gets
written there's 10 to 100 news articles
most news that's published is less than
a thousand words that is on a deadline
of a week or less
so respond to journalists fast
um
this is also why if you've ever had the
experience of a journalist who really
really really wants to talk to you you
may find them to be surprisingly dogged
uh it's because they if they've decided
that you are the person that they need
to talk to they are going to go to Great
Lengths to get a hold of you as quickly
as possible
um I have
uh
gone to a person's I mean well one one
standard tool for doing that is going to
the Press office for the University or
the person you want to talk to works
it's the Press office will go through
the channels of the university to get a
hold of that person
um another thing that I've done and I'm
not the only person who does this is uh
I will go to that person's website uh if
the person is a professor or
really I actually know that person's a
professor post-op grad student doesn't
matter they work in a lab presumably
I will find the names of other people in
that lab and call them
I will see if I can find what office
they're in and see who works in the
office next door
and call them and say hey can you see if
they're there
uh if I want to talk to a professor a
particularly effective way getting a
hold of professors calling that
professors graduate students
and saying hey I need to talk to your
boss
it's fine now I want to quote them in
Scientific American and I need to talk
to them today
so yeah respond quickly
um
you can ask if a journalist will show
you what they've written before it's
published but the answer is almost
always going to be no
it's the exact opposite of working with
the university press office
there's good reasons for this
um
basically it's a conflict of interest
it's an ethical issue
um the which is why journalists will
often say I can't my editor won't let me
because it's usually a policy of the
publication not to do that
um
because when you are talking with a
journalist for a news story it's it's
not the same as talking with the
university press office
you are a source for a piece of news
showing a source that news before it's
published for approval or disapproval
imagine somebody doing that for a
politics story
right that wouldn't be a good idea
and of course the motivation here is
different right when you ask can I see
it before it's published you want to
make sure that it's accurate because
there's a question of scientific
accuracy
it's not accurate that's unfortunately
not your problem now if you're not
quoted accurately that is your problem
and and you can talk to uh the news
outlet and they will do something to
address that
um
but you're not going to get to see it
before publication
so
um
keep that in mind while you're talking
to journalists
um
and
also keep in mind that what you're
saying is on the record
if unless unless you and the journalists
have agreed that it's not
it's going to be on the record
um
you know if somebody writes to you and
says hey I want to talk to you for this
piece and you say well
uh I don't have any comment on that
piece they can quote you saying I don't
have any comment on this piece
that's fair game
and that's not to scare you off
um most journalists are
fair-minded people who just want to get
the story and get it right
um
but in fact yeah it's important not to
be scared of journalists and I'm not
just saying this because I am one I'm
saying this because that fear I have
seen that fear Drive scientists do very
stupid things
for example there was a person I wanted
to talk with for a story and he somehow
got it in his head that I was
uh
interested in misrepresenting him he he
thought that I wanted to make him look
bad
there was no real reason for this I'd
never met him I've never spoken with him
he was not going to be a significant
component of what I was writing
which is good because he didn't agree to
talk with me but he sent me this very
long screed in response to my request
for interview
which was on the record I could have
published that
I didn't
but that you know he he shot himself in
the foot there
um and there's a good thing he was wrong
about me if my intention had been to
make him look bad he made it very easy
um yeah if a journalist yourself
yeah I know if you reply to the
journalist if the journalist says I want
to talk to you for this article
and you reply saying I don't want to
talk to you
you should assume that any conversation
you're having with a journalist who has
asked to interview you for an article is
on the record unless you and the
journalist have both agree there's no
armed by people like for instance
not unless you win the journalist agree
so you can think of anything you're
interested
I could I I mean
are you saying I'm only willing to talk
to you off the Record that the
journalist says that's fine
then you can talk to them or email them
and that won't be on the record you know
you could say I'm only comfortable
talking with you if you quote me
anonymously and the journalist says
that's fine
but
both parties have to agree
yeah no I mean
there are limits to that right for
example say that I email you
and ask you to talk on the record for a
story and I get an auto reply from you
if I represented that auto reply as
something that you said that would be
journalistic malpractice that would be
an ethical breach
um
but yeah
I mean in practice if a journalist
emails you and says hey I want to talk
with you and you say no thanks I don't
want to comment on this paper
but in theory you could as saying you
don't have comments on the page
all right
[Music]
it's about relevant or Central to the
story
that like that why
yeah that's right
that's correct yeah yeah yeah yeah
the only situation in which I or most
journalists would say so and so
and so it was an important character of
the story that's right yeah so like if
you wrote a paper and then that paper
got retracted despite the journal
because somebody else said hey it's got
this serious problems crap and I wrote
you and said hey do you have any comment
on this and he wrote back saying I can't
comment I quote
if I was writing about a normal piece of
you know news and I was like okay who
else Works in this area and I came
across you I said oh can you comment on
this piece of work that you weren't
involved in which is a standard thing
uh to do when you're writing about a
piece of work is to get inside comment
on it because you want to know what the
community is
because if you said I don't want to
comment on that I would probably not
quote you
and if everyone said I don't want to
comment on that that might kill the
story
um because it's usually
instead of practice is not removed but
uh usually if people don't want to
comment on something no one's willing to
comment on it
that tells you something about the
community perception of the paper at
least it's not important or no one's
about it put some things in like never
no one's willing to read it
right about
it on sweat
but yeah yeah in general
um
in general a journalist is not going to
publish what you say if it's something
like I don't want to talk about
because
unless you are yourself Central
I mean even if I were writing a better
paper you wrote and you said I don't
want to talk about it I just go find one
of your co-authors and I wouldn't
mention that we wouldn't want to talk
about it
unless there was a really competencies
that's all oh my god well I'm happy to
talk about anything any questions you
have about anything I've talked about
any questions about transition that I
made professionally from science
journalism or from scientific research
into science journalism
um anything about writing books writing
for newspapers writing for magazines
um we had also your share of scientific
papers and how much of this storytelling
sort of ideas transferred to the type of
writing that we typically do in our own
research papers and our talks and our
grant writing are there lessons
yeah I think um
clear writing is always a good idea
I think that being able to clearly lay
out the story behind why you care about
a particular subject
I was particularly compelling for grant
writing
um
and uh and also like
introductions to Scientific papers are
often I think missed opportunities to
tell stories right
um because you know they're you're
supposed to be laying out the background
of what you're writing about there's
different ways of doing that you know
you could say the question of so-and-so
was first approached by Smith at all in
um and then there were these papers that
went after it or you could say okay this
question is interesting because of this
if we were able to find that answer to
that question we'd be able to do this
this and this it'll lead to progress in
these areas uh it receives a lot of
attention and some of the most important
stuff was here here and here right like
one of those
there are a lot of papers that do the
first thing when they could do the
second thing
so yeah I think storytelling is usually
a good idea
so you have the opportunity
what are you writing about now
uh I am writing about
um
how Silicon Valley gets the future wrong
and often folks science as a
justification for ideas about the future
that
there's a no basis and scientific fact
about how you get stuff placed um
pitching things because I feel like
right now even if I had something to say
yeah an editor would be like who's this
Rando
yeah with if I don't have an expensive
you know list of public writing
absolutely absolutely so um
uh this is what I call the Catch 22 of
journalism right uh you need or this is
true in many fields uh you need to have
a portfolio in order to get work but you
need to do work in order to build a
portfolio right
um
so
there are a few ways out of that
um One Way Out is to go talk with your
University press office and say hey I'm
an expert in this field do you need some
help writing about it I would love to
get some experience
um another way out uh if you are a
student or post-op is to take a look at
something called AAA as fast via
Fellowship AAA American Association for
advanced science uh runs a mass media
Fellowship every summer for 10 weeks for
current students and recently graduated
students and postdocs in The Sciences
broadly construed
um to give people
experience in professional journalism
and science right because they will take
the group of fellows get a fellowship
and embed them in various news
organizations for 10 weeks over the
summer
um and you walk out of there with a
portfolio and a set of connections those
are the people that you worked with and
with the other fellows
Ah that's a great way out of that
um if you're looking to make a complete
career shift
um that's one way and another way is to
do one of the science writing Master's
programs uh like UC Santa Cruz or MIT
and Brad NYU
there are others but those are the three
that I'm the most familiar with
um
another way in
that is harder
um is to try to find places that are
smaller places that are willing to take
your writing without having a lot of
examples of your writing to begin with
um even for that you'll probably need a
portfolio but it can be just stuff that
you've written that hasn't been
published anywhere like a blog or
something
um and then sort of build your way up
from there
that's horrible but it can be done
sure other than yourself who do you
think are really good
science writers what makes you think I
think
okay taking yourself out of the
competition or whatever reason you want
to foreign
I think
ah
maybe just names of names in no
particular order
um
uh Ed young uh Natalie Walker I'm a man
[Music]
older people who are not that active
anymore but um Annie Dillard
um
yeah
Katie Mack is is not in the older
category that's going back to you know
um
there are a lot of really good people
um that is not a comprehensive list at
all
so we didn't mention Gina colada I don't
know what that is
is that it's sorry
oh yeah I was just curious to hear about
your career trajectory and your
transition sure yeah um so there's a
long version of the short version I'll
give you the short version we can talk
about the whole version language but uh
the short version is that I did not do
any of them I just said as advice for
how to break it and like break actually
too
um because I was incredibly lucky
um
um by the time I finished my PhD that
was pretty clearly the direction I
wanted to go in but I wasn't sure if I
could make it happen
um I
um
I
I applied to the AAA SMS media
Fellowship to try to break that
captioning too but I also found out
about an internship in scientists
magazine member San Francisco offense
which
um
Peter all this by the time it was ahead
of the San Francisco office I was
looking for someone who
as well
um because he wanted someone to build
with interactive pieces from your
scientific site
um
PhD work
building websites built one for him he
hired me even though I didn't have a
portfolio other than a vlog that I have
but nobody read I was maintaining only
as a writing portfolio
yeah so he hired me that gave me a
portfolio
um and
um
probably figure out how to make that out
that particular career path is
completely impossible because
um it is
basically unheard of to get an
internship like those six month
internships
are like the entry level positions in
science writing they are paid not very
well but they're paid
um but you can't get them without a
portfolio the fact that I got one
without a portfolio is
incredibly lucky and also new scientists
doesn't even have a San Francisco Bureau
anymore
and Peter does not work there anymore
so yeah
okay sure yeah
uh what made you know that you wanted to
do science journalism sure
um
I
liked doing scientific research but I
did not think that I was
responding
um
the odds of getting a job in Academia
are pretty low or in any sort of
research position there aren't that many
research positions outside of
uh that there are no research positions
in cosmology outside of Academia and
National Labs
um and getting permanent position either
of those is basically unheard of I
wasn't sure it was what I wanted anyway
I like the work but I there's a certain
level of modern Mania required in
Academia and I didn't think I had that
um
I also noticed that I like talking with
other people about their research and
about my research more than actually
doing research
um and that suggested
science writing as a direction and also
science communication not the same thing
as journalism uh was something that I've
been doing for a really long time
um and had always enjoyed and I like
writing and I thought okay well I'm not
a fantastic physicist and I'm not a
fantastic writer uh but I am a better
writer than most physicists and I
definitely know a lot more physics than
most writers
and so that might be a more successful
direction for a career and more
enjoyable
um and that turned out to be right
anybody else we're at time but I can
keep going yeah
foreign
um
yeah
it's a good question there's a piece of
writing about writing that I really like
called politics in the English language
by George Orwell
and he he has a set of sort of
suggestions or rules about writing in
there
um one of them is you know uh something
along the lines of you know if you can
cut a word you should
um
I think in general that's true but in
practice it's not
um like always true it's like
okay there's another there's another
[Music]
um
idea I don't have a good reference for
this but the the idea that like
things should be the length that they
need to be
um
I think that
in general being shorter can be better
but it really depends on what you want
to do
um
you know each idea or story you want to
tell has
a particular format that works best for
it right like um oh there's this pivot
to video that a lot of journalistic
outlets really wanted to do like a few
years back because Facebook had lied
about their metrics and said that video
was getting more engagement when that
wasn't true uh and so everybody suddenly
started making videos problem is that
there's a lot of stories for which video
is at best Superfluous and at worst the
wrong format if you want to tell a story
that doesn't really have much of a
visual component why are you making a
video about it
similarly people wanted to make a lot of
interactive content because they could
um which uh to to cite another academic
they were thinking so much about whether
they could they didn't stop to think
about whether they should
um
but uh
it depends on the story
you know if it's a story that can be
told in 500 Words and you take a
thousand
that's not the end of the world but you
should probably have done it in 500
Words there are a lot of books that
should have been feature articles
instead of being 80 000 words they
should have been three thousand votes
um that's partly a symptom of the fact
that a lot of books start life as
feature articles then the feature
article gets a lot of praise and someone
says have you ever thought about writing
a book about that and the answer is well
no but now I'm thinking about it and uh
and then they sort of
get a bicycle pump and try to blow it up
into a book
um but um
but yeah
um
but then there are some things that have
to be books
and you can't do them in anything less
than that so I don't think there's a
simple
you know all the time rule there
um
I do think it's a general law of the
universe that if you give people a word
limit they won't meet that limit the
work expands to fill the space allotted
so yeah
I don't know if that's a satisfying
answer
um hold on I want to see if anybody else
has questions
okay go ahead yes thanks
sometimes you have the option of
writing something in the latex and some
kinds of a supplementary message about
pendants obviously
yeah
um
usually they end up using something like
that if there's something that I really
want to say but I can't find if they put
it into the store
um
so like
you know if there is some subject
that
really seem like some idea or topic or
whatever that seems relevant to what I'm
talking about but I just can't seem to
fit it into the story The Narrative that
I'm telling
that's usually a sign that it's not
actually essential
but if it's interesting anyway
well then maybe it's a footnote or an
endnote or an appendix
um
yeah
anybody else
well there's your questions I think
upstairs maybe we can continue the
conversation absolutely yeah
well thank you
foreign